3000 quadratkilometer natur
mit gewaltigen landschaften und einer
erstaunlichen artenvielfalt
[Musik]
das ist schön so wie es ist
man muss nichts verändern wir sollten es
so bewahren
[Musik]
manch einer der hierher kommt beginnt
umzudenken
[Musik]
man empfinde doch schon noch ein
bisschen mehr was wirklich wichtig ist
im leben hier aus nur ein paradies der
superlative die heimat märchenhafter
bäume der mensch ist nicht mehr als ein
kleiner gast auf 3000 jahre alten riesen
ganz sicher waren mehr menschen auf dem
mount everest als hier oben auf einem
mammutbaum ich habe so ein glück dass
das hier sozusagen mein büro ist
millionen touristen entfliehen jedes
jahr den modernen leben um in dieser
wildnis kraft zu tanken oder sich mit
ihren herausforderungen zu messen
eine natur friedlich und unberechenbar
zugleich
eine insel im meer der zivilisation
geschützt aber auch bedroht
der yosemite nationalpark
[Musik]
roman und markus aus österreich sind vor
allem aus einem grund hier
sie wollen an diesem tag einen der
gewaltige granitfelsen besteigen
die rohmarge es denn für sie ist der
yosemite nationalpark ein traumziel und
eine besondere herausforderung
sie wissen dass sie hier gleich fast
senkrechte wände erwarten
dieser park in den usa ist berühmt für
seine einzigartige gebirgslandschaft die
das yosemite tal säumt wie der runde
half dome oder der cathedral rock
[Musik]
es geht los
der aufstieg von rund 400 metern wird
etwa drei stunden dauern
da müssen roman und markus ihre kraft
gut einteilen
die kletterei ist alles andere als
harmlos über 900 menschen verunglückten
bereits an den felswänden des yosemite
nationalparks das wissen auch die beiden
abhalten kann es sie trotzdem nicht
[Musik]
schneller ist es schwer ist es
ungesichert
und wenn man es geschafft hat dann im
endeffekt da ist es schon leistung gutes
gefühl
da riecht man einfach kletterer von der
großen welt die was aber eigentlich alle
das ganze team
konkret anzugehen und da hat man gleich
einen anschluss punkt und kommen mit
ihren kleinen mal ins gespräch kämen
jetzt einen kette gebieten in amerika
gehört haben wo man hinfahren
da haben wir schon wieder für ziele für
die nächsten samstag der yosemite
nationalpark liegt mitten in kalifornien
den bevölkerungsreichsten staat der usa
los angeles und san francisco sind nur
wenige autostunden entfernt der park
umfasst eine fläche von 3.000
quadratkilometern in den bergen der
sierra nevada
ein großteil davon ist besonders
geschützte wildnis in die sich kaum
besucher verirren
die meisten halten sich nur in einem
kleinen teil auf die wand des el
capitano 1000 meter hoch ist eines der
wahrzeichen des parks ein felsvorsprung
windows ist ein kick für kletterer auch
für roman und markus
das große ziel war natürlich deutlich
kapital über dinos wir trainieren
momentan auf das ziel hin
wir haben von anfang an gesagt wir wohin
die hosen gehen wenn man vorher tags
darauf trainieren können
er war der rennt nicht weg den berg es
gibt für ziemlich alle berge das am
meisten flugzeuge und was dann kommt
mein 3er wieder also ich bin mir sicher
dass sie wieder her kommt auf jeden fall
eine natur die aber auch höchst
gefährliche tücken hat zwei felsstürze
am l kapital in diesem jahr ein
bergsteiger kommt dabei ums leben
weitere menschen werden verletzt
[Musik]
eine steinplatte groß wie ein
einfamilienhaus war zu tal gestürzt
diese besucher hat noch glück es kam
eine menge staub und granit runter und
traf das auto das glasdach ging kaputt
und ein stein traf den fahrer
er hat eine gehirnerschütterung und
einen schädelbruch
sie mussten per helikopter aus fliegen
seine frau meine frau und ich saßen auch
im wagen
wir sind gott sei dank nicht verletzt
wir haben es überlebt ein so großer
felssturz ist außergewöhnlich auch nach
ansicht der parkmitarbeiter scott
gerdemann ist dennoch nicht überrascht
die steinschläge haben eine natürliche
ursache
das kann magnetismus sein oder etwas
anderes das abblättern von felsen kommt
häufig vor
das ist der yosemite nationalpark der s
p definition wird dieses jahr hatten wir
umstürzende bäume überflutungen
feuerstein schläge
das sind natürliche prozesse diese
zerstörungen werden nicht beseitigt das
wird der natur selbst überlassen
sie reguliert wie so oft das leben im
park
nur scheinbar wirkt hier alles ruhig und
ewig gleich
doch die zuweilen extremen
witterungsbedingungen sorgen für
ständige veränderungen gerade wenn es
nach dem winter oft monatelang nicht
regnet
mit der trockenheit kommen dann oft
heftige brände vor allem in den letzten
jahren lag kalifornien unter einer
extremen dürre 80 prozent der feuer sind
durch menschen verursacht viele durch
unachtsamkeit
der yosemite nationalpark ist bisher nur
teilweise betroffen
die feuerwehren sind ständig gefordert
den park zu schützen
verstärkung erhalten ihre mannschaften
durch ganz ungewöhnliche mitarbeiter es
sind häftlinge des bundesstaates
kalifornien ihr gefängnis ist hier
mitten in der wildnis nur mit gutem
verhalten schaffen sie es aus der
regulären haftanstalt in dieses programm
denn auf sie muss verlass sein je 15
häftlinge werden bei der arbeit von nur
einem einzigen feuerwehrmann betreut
abfahrt zur arbeit eindruck ist an
diesem tag unterwegs in den yosemite
nationalpark wo er eine feuerschutz
schneise in den wald schlagen wird
die gefangenen dürfen daher mit allem
notwendigen werkzeug arbeiten inklusive
kettensäge welche straftaten sie
begangen haben darüber möchten sie nicht
sprechen
für den einsatzleiter kerkener ist das
vergehen aber auch nicht entscheidend
ich behandle die häftlinge wie jeden
erwachsenen
jeder will doch gerecht behandelt werden
und das ist mir wichtig nicht jeder hält
es wie ich aber sie sind doch männer und
zu nehmen sie war außer natürlich sie
benehmen sich daneben
dann müssen wir sie daran erinnern wo
sie hier sind für die häftlinge ist es
ein langer weg bis sie in den crews
arbeiten dürfen
richard war 15 jahre in einem normalen
gefängnis bevor er vor zwei jahren zum
camp wechselte und hier seinen platz
fand
wir haben bei einer überschwemmung mit
sandsäcken ein haus geschützt
der besitzer war zu tränen gerührt und
es war ein gutes gefühl diesen mann und
seiner familie zu helfen
so leiste ich meinen beitrag zur
gesellschaft viele von ihnen sind stolz
auf das was sie hier tun denn der
yosemite nationalpark es fast so etwas
wie ein nationalheiligtum gerade für die
california eine leidenschaft mit langer
tradition
[Musik]
die parkverwaltung gepflegt ein
umfangreiches archiv eine sammlung viele
reiseberichte und notizen zahlreicher
forscher sie alle waren überwältigt von
der natur und wollten sie erhalten
doch niemand prägte den park sowie der
schottische abenteurer jean mio
obwohl der park schon seit 1864 unter
staatlichem schutz stand
mit die natur unter bergbau und
landwirtschaft nur überredete us
präsident theodore roosevelt drei tage
mit ihm im park zu campieren
mit erfolg seit 1906 sorgt ein strenges
bundesgesetz für die unantastbarkeit des
parks doch der schuss hatte unerwartete
folgen die zahlreichen schwarzbären
begannen zu verstehen dass von den
besuchern keine gefahr ausgeht
im gegenteil die tiere verlangten einen
teil ihrer natürlichen scheu ließen sich
füttern oder griffen touristen an einige
beeren starben durch den verzehr von
resten aus dem müll oder wo sie gerade
etwas essbares fanden und dabei war so
gut wie nichts vor ihnen sicher
[Musik]
erst in den letzten jahrzehnten verstand
man dass es eines managements aller
wildtiere und ihrer besucher bedarf
zuständig ist die kalifornische
jagdbehörde nähten greve leyen ist einer
der ranger er ist für das gebiet direkt
außerhalb des parks verantwortlich
probleme gibt es viele
so existiert kein zaun und die tiere
wissen nicht wo ihr geschützter bereich
endet
[Musik]
die herausforderung mit den bären in
yosemite ist dass da so viele leute sind
der bären bestand wird auch nicht
wirklich kontrolliert das ist schon ein
problem dass beides zu managen
viele bären in dem gebiet und viele
leute im park ist es bei strafe verboten
lebensmittel im freien zu lagern
müll darf nur in gesicherten containern
entsorgt werden
problembären werden gefangen und in
einsamen gegenden ausgesetzt eine jagd
auf sie findet nicht statt
innerhalb des naturreservats sind fast
alle tiere geschützt
mason kontrolliert einen jäger der
außerhalb des parks einen hirsch erlegt
hat das darf er umgerechnet knapp 70
euro kostet in dieser abschuss lizenz
also ich mache jetzt ein loch in deiner
jagd lizenz damit ist sie entwertet wenn
ich nur darüber schreibe könnte man das
wieder abwischen
der mann hat sich gesetzlich korrekt
verhalten
seine beute gemeldet das tier weit
manish zerlegt dutzende jäger sind an
diesem morgen unterwegs
aber nicht alle mit lizenz illegale
jäger ja es gibt hier wilderer gerade
gestern hat einer eine hirschkuh
geschossen leute jagen nachts obwohl es
verboten ist oder außerhalb der saison
nur selten bekommt nation wilderer zu
gesicht hier entdeckt er einen
futterplatz zunächst vermutet er jemand
würde pferde versorgen doch
zitrusfrüchte und ein intensiv duftende
stück schokolade fressen pferde nicht
das sieht aus als würde jemand an den
beeren anlocken wollen
ich hatte gehofft ich würde mich
täuschen aber ich muss das der jagd auf
sicht melden
wie sollen sich das ansehen vielleicht
verstecken die dann kameras das ist
schon was umgerechnet etwa 80 euro
kostet die erlaubnis einen schwarzbären
zu erlegen
manche scheinen sich selbst das sparen
zu wollen
im park selbst ist von all dem nichts zu
spüren
außer ein wenig angela ist jegliche jagd
verboten
anschauen aber nicht anfassen ist ein
fast schon heiliger grundsatz in
yosemite nationalpark
[Musik]
das einzigartige natur paradies steht
jedem besucher offen
wer mit dem auto kommt zahlt umgerechnet
25 euro
naturforscher setzen zudem auf die
vermittlung von wissen wie peek die war
ein
er kennt den park wie seine westentasche
und öffnet besuchern die sinne für so
manches geheimnis dieser baum hat eine
tolle überraschung bereit
er ist eine kiefer eine jeffrey pein und
er riecht ganz besonders ich finde es
immer spannend was die menschen damit
assoziieren vanille butter karamell auf
jeden fall wie eine gute bäckerei ich
habe ihn oft angeknabbert aber ich mag
den geschmack nicht
es bleibt nur der geruch auf seinen
wanderungen durch den park ist immer auf
der suche nach den schönsten routen für
seine nächsten besucher
[Musik]
nach fünf jahren trockenheit gab es im
vergangenen winter viel schnee in den
höhen des parks selbst im juni sind
manche seiner lieblings pfade noch
vereist
[Musik]
das ist erstaunlich
im sommer ist hier sonst ein trockener
weg der eigentliche fluss kommt erst
noch
ich denke wir sollten eine andere route
wählen
im hochland werden wir wohl auch im
sommer mit bächen und schnee rechnen
müssen wohl noch nie welche waren
je höher er geht desto karger wird die
landschaft etwa die hälfte des parks
befindet sich im gebirge oberhalb von
2500 metern
hier wachsen nur noch wenige der 1500
pflanzenarten die der park beherbergt
mehr als 100 davon gelten als gefährdet
denn umwelteinflüsse und der klimawandel
machen nicht vor den grenzen des parks
halt
[Musik]
man es leicht versucht den yosemite
nationalpark als insel wahrzunehmen
man blickt auf die karte und sind diese
präzise gezogene grenze die rheininsel
förmiges stück landschaft markiert aber
wir sind natürlich mit dem rest der welt
verbunden
eine unserer größten herausforderungen
ist eben diese einbindung wir wissen
seit jahrzehnten dass der klimawandel
auch hier stattfindet und das mit einem
rasanten tempo
das erkennt man auch an mehreren orten
im park wir sind keine entkoppelte insel
sondern mit der umliegenden landschaft
fest verbunden
rund fünf millionen besucher aus aller
welt suchen in der oase jedes jahr
erholung verbunden ist dies mit einer
weiteren belastung einer umwelt die
ohnehin unter industrie und verkehr
erleidet der yosemite nationalpark ist
auch eine wichtige lebensader dieser
region städte und landwirtschaft
profitieren von seinen ressourcen saugen
frischwasser aus seinem gebirge die
region fördert wiederum den park
unterstützt ihnen mit
forschungsprojekten und
umweltinitiativen
[Musik]
der großteil der besucher kommt aus den
städten der umgebung zu hunderttausenden
entfliehen sie jedes wochenende dem
alltagsstress um im yosemite tal
erholung zu finden
das führt zu kilometerlangen staus und
wartezeiten
wer den berühmten haftung besteigen will
muss an einer lotterie teilnehmen
doch wer sich in die schier unendlichen
tiefen des parks wagt kann die
einsamkeit und endlose weite dieser
wildnis noch kennenlernen eine welt wie
sie einst die ersten siedler
kaliforniens erlebt haben
[Musik]
es ist genau diese ruhe und
abgeschiedenheit die auch joachim seele
hier sucht 2009 kam er aus deutschland
nach kalifornien
er studierte politik beschäftigt sich
jetzt mit erneuerbarer energie und
analysiert die amerikanischen
energiemärkte er arbeitet in einem büro
und san francisco
250 kilometer vom park entfernt freitag
nach der arbeit sachen im kofferraum
schmeißen ins auto und dann los mit ein
paar freunden und dann einfach ein
schönes langes wochenende hier draußen
verbringen dann ist man doch relativ
schnell ab vom schuss und hat wirklich
die ruhe weg
er ist mir danach doch schon und wieder
gehärtet und wie man empfindet doch
schon noch ein bisschen mehr was
wirklich wichtig ist im leben präsident
trumps umwelt politik macht ihm sorgen
joachim segel spürt aber widerstand in
der region gerade kalifornien hat
momentan schon sehr stark so ne
gallische dorf mentalität gegenüber den
der neuen nationalregierung viele
amerikaner schauen auch momentan ausland
und ist nicht so ganz genau was sie
davon halten sollen und finden sich da
selbst nicht wieder
die regierung in washington investiert
derzeit eher in das militär als in
mutter natur
immerhin in kalifornien gelten die
strengsten umweltgesetze der usa in
diesem bundesstaat scheinen die bewohner
sensibler zu sein wenn es um den schutz
ihrer region geht
[Musik]
der mono see östlich des parks seine
geschichte zeigt wie sich engagierte
california erfolgreich für die natur
eingesetzt haben
matschiners umweltschutzorganisation
kämpfte gegen die großstadt los angeles
diese leitete immer mehr frischwasser
aus den zuflüssen des mondsees ab der
mono war schon fast ganz verschwunden
da wäre nur eine pfütze mit so einer art
salzlake übrig geblieben und nur wegen
der wasserversorgung für los angeles
er hat einen dreimal so hohen salzgehalt
wie ein ozean durch das ableiten des
frischwassers erhöhte sich die
konzentration noch mehr
[Musik]
der wasserspiegel war früher viel höher
bestimmt zehn meter der see ging hinauf
bis ganz dort hinten
umweltschützern gelang es die stadt los
angeles vor gericht zu zwingen
sie gewannen den prozess ein meilenstein
für die kalifornische umweltbewegung
seitdem ist der verbrauch des wassers
reguliert doch das heißt nicht dass der
kampf für immer gewonnen ist
[Musik]
viele menschen in den usa akzeptieren
dass es den klimawandel gibt
ich glaube aber auch dass es eine menge
gibt die das nicht tun
oder sie wollen nicht dass etwas dagegen
unternommen wird denn sie haben etwas
dabei zu verlieren
so einfach ist das der yosemite
nationalpark liegt im gebirgszug der
sierra nevada vor 150 jahren kamen die
menschen auf der suche nach gold
heute ist ein anderer schatz weitaus
wichtiger wasser
im winter hält es der schnee als
natürlicher speicher fest doch nur wenn
es kalt genug ist
[Musik]
matschie miller will zeigen wie es um
den yosemite nationalpark als
natürliches wasserreservoir bestellt ist
es geht letztlich darum ob davon auch in
zukunft genügend zur verfügung stehen
wird
sowohl für den mono see als auch für die
versorgung der städte in der umgebung
für die beurteilung der wasservorräte
spielen die gletscher eine entscheidende
rolle
wir werden jetzt zum dinner gletscher
hoch gehen und uns dort umschauen
wir wollen sehen wie sich der
klimawandel dort auswirkt vor über einer
million jahren formten gigantische
gletscher das berühmte yosemite tal
die spektakulären täler die schroffen
felsen kamen zum vorschein als sich die
eisriesen zurückzogen
unter den gipfeln fanden die ersten
naturforscher noch vor 150 jahren große
eisfelder matschie miller sind daher
historische aufnahmen von besonderem
interesse
der erste geologe hier oben war ein mann
namens israel russell
er sollte die ganze gegend
kartografieren das war 1883 und er
machte bei der gelegenheit ein foto des
taylor gletschers
mein ziel ist es genau diese steinige zu
finden
[Musik]
matschie miller will von genau dem platz
aus ein foto des gletschers machen den
schon israel russell nutzte er ist
überrascht
am vortag ist schnee gefallen
ungewöhnlich für diese jahreszeit
[Musik]
ich liebe es hier es ist so schön wir
haben so ein glück dass wir hier noch
die reste des gletschers erleben können
denn in 20 bis 50 jahren gibt es die
nicht mehr
überhaupt kein eisfeld wir sind die
letzten die gletscher in der sierra
nevada sehen können
der frische schnee macht es für bartsch
immer schwieriger den genaueres des
gletschers zu fotografieren
anhand von messdaten und früheren fotos
kann er die veränderung der eisflächen
dennoch gut darstellen
auf dem schwarz weiß foto von damals
sehen wir den umriss des feldes von 1883
ich nehme das bild von israel raffel
raus dann sieht man meines mit dem
umriss des gletschers von damals der
eindruck täuscht unter dem schnee liegt
nur noch wenig eis das habe ich gelb
umrandet das ist der klimawandel der
gletscher ist fast weg angesichts solch
gewaltiger wasserfälle im yosemite
nationalpark mag man an einem
wassermangel zweifeln
doch wissenschaftler richten ihren blick
auf den rückzug der gletscher als
alarmzeichen für immer länger andauernde
warme und trockene phasen
das hätte auch außerhalb des parks große
auswirkungen auf die natur die anwohner
aber auch auf die intensive
landwirtschaft versorgungsprobleme mit
wasser haben die farmer schon heute
kalifornien ist eine agrar supermacht
400 verschiedenen nutzpflanzen werden
hier angebaut
zwei drittel der in den usa produzierte
nüsse und früchte kommen aus kalifornien
drei viertel der produkte gehen zu
verbrauchern in den usa der rest wird in
die ganze welt exportiert das wohl
berühmteste exportprodukt kaliforniens
ist die mandel
sie steht sinnbildlich für die gesamte
landwirtschaft der region und es
berüchtigt für ihren hohen wasserbedarf
[Musik]
farmer del bosques überprüft gerade das
noch unreife steinobst die ernte ist
erst im herbst
[Musik]
die mandel gibt uns sogar zwei produkte
denn diese hülle wird als tierfutter
genutzt
in den letzten jahren der trockenheit
sind die mandeln bauern in die kritik
geraten weil ihre bäume zu viel wasser
verbrauchen
[Musik]
man ist so fokussiert darauf welche
pflanzen wie viel wasser brauchen
mandeln sind nicht durstiger als
pfirsiche oder kirschen aber sie sind
sehr ins bewusstsein der menschen
gerückt weil wir immer mehr davon
anbauen
dabei richten wir uns doch nur noch der
weltweiten nachfrage zu del bosques und
seine kollegen haben dennoch eine
strategie wir verwenden 35 prozent
weniger wasser als vor 30 jahren
erzielen aber 40 ernte wir haben uns
also angepasst
wir berechnen genau welcher baum wie
viel braucht um früchte zu tragen
jeder tropfen wasser ist teuer
dadurch liegen felder brach auf den
restlichen ackerflächen bleibt dennoch
viel zu tun
ein harter job denn viele amerikaner
nicht übernehmen wollen dafür
beschäftigen die bauern saison arbeiter
aus zentral- und südamerika und zahlen
ihnen bis zu 50 prozent über dem
mindestlohn nicht wenige sind illegal
hier im juli erreichten wir den
höhepunkt der ernte da arbeiten hier
mehr als 300 menschen
wir landwirte müssen uns für die
einwanderer einsetzen indem wir mit der
regierung sprechen und ihnen klarmachen
dass wir diese menschen brauchen wenn
sie alle des landes verwiesen werden
haben wir niemanden der in den feldern
arbeitet
bis zu 65 stunden fällt dabei pro woche
in der hochsaison für mandeln in unseren
supermärkten so kennt selbst dieses
leben wenn ich diese arbeiter sehe ist
das wie ein blick in die vergangenheit
meiner eigenen familie
sie ist erst vor 100 jahren in die usa
gekommen und sie haben genauso in den
feldern gearbeitet
mein vater hat mir damit ermöglicht auf
die uni zu gehen und so mein eigenes
unternehmen zu gründen
und nun beginnt ihr amerikanischer traum
mit den grundbedürfnissen sie wollen
ihre familie ernähren und ein haus zum
leben haben und hoffen ihren kindern
eine bessere zukunft zu ermöglichen eine
zukunft womöglich mit rationierten
frischwasser ein teil der landschaft ist
bereits ab gesunken weil die bauern so
viel grundwasser abgepumpt haben
[Musik]
auch die wälder rund um den yosemite
nationalpark bekommen den massiven
wassermangel zu spüren
feuerwehrmann und försterling nielsen
begutachtet die schäden regelmäßig 70
prozent der nadelbäume haben die
trockenen jahre nicht überlebt
wegen der dürre sind die bäume
angeschlagen sie sind also geschwächt
und das nutzen die borkenkäfer aus es
gibt diese insekten schon immer in
dieser region
aber nun haben sie ein leichtes spiel
die bäume anzugreifen und ihr bestand
ist exponentiell gestiegen
der gefährliche schädlinge schlägt dort
zu wo er am wenigsten widerstand erhält
durch die trockenheit der geschwächten
bäume gelingt es nicht die borkenkäfer
abzuhalten so überfallen die insekten
einen baum nach dem anderen überleben
die trockenen winter und vermehren sich
nielsen stellt immer wieder fest dass
sie auch gesunde bäume schädigen
hier sieht man ihre wege unter der rinde
wo sie eindringen ihre eier legen und
wieder verschwinden
dieser baum ist schon mindestens ein
jahr tot er verrottet jetzt und
irgendwann fällt er einfach um ein
windstoß kann genügen
[Applaus]
dicht an der grenze wohnen viele
menschen in kleinen ortschaften
auch hier müssen tote bäume entfernt
werden das baumsterben erstreckt sich
vom süden kaliforniens quer durch den
yosemite nationalpark bis in den norden
des bundesstaates
viele menschen finden es schön im wald
zu leben
10 oder 20 bäume im garten zu haben war
einmal eine wertsteigerung für ein
grundstück jetzt sind die bäume tod und
daher gefährlich und teuer zu entfernen
[Musik]
60 millionen bäume starben allein im
jahr 2016 in ganz kalifornien im park
sind 2,4 millionen geschädigt
die frage ist sollte man neu bepflanzen
oder gehört das sterben zum zyklus eines
naturparks
[Musik]
immerhin die mammutbäume im park haben
auf den ersten blick bisher kaum schaden
genommen
für viele besucher sind die riesen ein
hauptgrund hierherzukommen squires wie
sie auch heißen wachsen vor allem im
süden des parks und sind bis zu 90 meter
hoch welchen einfluss der klimawandel
auf die bäume genommen hat wollen die
ökologin wenn die baxter und ihr team
herausfinden
wir wollen heute proben von zwei dieser
bäume nehmen um wasserdruck messungen
vorzunehmen
das ist so eine art blutdruckmessung an
bäumen um zu sehen wie gestresst sie
durch die trockenheit sind
die sierra nevada ist die heimat der
mammutbäume als teil dieser region
stehen einige dieser majestätischen
pflanzen im yosemite nationalpark
denn der untergrund führt sehr viel
grundwasser das aus den bergen hier
hindurch fließt
mit diesen vorgängen hat sich der
wissenschaftler anthony andrews intensiv
beschäftigt wir konnten nachweisen dass
ein einziger dieser bäume pro tag bis zu
2000 liter wasser nach oben
transportiert mehr als irgendein anderer
baum auf diesem planeten kann um proben
zu entnehmen muss das team in die
baumwipfel und 90 meter hoch mit pfeil
und bogen wurde eine angelschnur über
einen ast geschossen danach ein
kletterseil nachgezogen
der helm ist pflicht bäume sind
lebewesen manchmal verlieren sie ihre
erste die können die auf den kopf fallen
oder der arzt auf dem besteht bricht ab
und du fällst ein stück das ist nicht
ohne risiko wenn irgendetwas runterfällt
schreien wir kopfschmerzen um die leute
hier am boden zu warnen
die aktion ist ein kraftakt wendy und
ihr team haben ein paar dutzend bäume in
ihrem programm schaffen vier bis fünf
riesen pro tag
jeder aufstieg dauert gut eine stunde
[Musik]
ich werde jetzt proben einsammeln
ich brauche vier stück damit es
einigermaßen repräsentativ für den wie
wir sagen stresslevel ist die müssen da
entnommen werden wohin die sonne scheint
es geht darum mit welchem druck das
wasser bis in die höchsten zweige
gelangt die bisherigen untersuchungen
zeigen die dürre ist auch hier messbar
aber den mammutbäumen scheint es noch
gut zu gehen
fast 3000 jahre sind einige von ihnen
alt es sind sehr robuste bäume nicht
umsonst werden sie tausende jahre alt
und bis zu 90 meter hoch und trotzdem
die bedingungen ändern sich gerade
weltweit auch hier in der sierra nevada
das wasser aus den schneemassen wird
weniger die temperaturen steigen das
alles ändert sich sehr schnell und wir
wissen nicht wie diese bäume darauf
reagieren die mammutbäume sind der
steigenden luftverschmutzung permanent
ausgesetzt
das zentrale becken von kalifornien
füllt sich immer wieder mit morgen vor
allem aus den großen städten doch ein
großer teil der verschmutzten luft
stammt aus asien in den hohen luft
strömen wird das über den pazifik nach
kalifornien transportiert doch von hier
kommt auch gutes genauer aus der wüste
gobi feinste phosphor partikel
sie werden ebenfalls nach kalifornien
gewählt lege sich auf den waldboden und
unterstützen so die mammutbäume bei
ihrer photosynthese ein weltweites
netzwerk der natur
[Musik]
es ist herbst wieder einmal brennt es
werden häuser und felder zerstört
einem regenreichen jahresbeginn war ein
außergewöhnlich trockener sommer gefolgt
der zahlreiche neue bewuchs verdorrte
und ergab so reichlich futter für die
flammen
es brennt wie es kalifornien noch nie
erlebt hat
kennt kann euer der feuerwehrmann ist
auf dem weg zur einsatzbesprechung der
brandschutz rund um den see mit die
nationalpark muss neu koordiniert werden
maßnahmen um das naturparadies und seine
umgebung vor dem alles vernichtenden
feuer so gut es geht zu schützen
aber zunächst einmal sollen die schäden
beseitigt werden
60 häuser wurden zerstört zahlreiche
straßen blockiert
canon und sein trupp strafgefangener
räumen eine zufahrt frei diesjährige
saison war die schlimmste bisher
[Musik]
ein feuer ging genau durch unser camp
die meiste zeit hatten wir damit zu tun
unsere eigene gegend zu schützen
das war unser erstes ziel aber wir haben
geholfen wo wir konnten die jungs hatten
wirklich viel zu tun mit kleinen und
größeren bränden
die meisten von ihnen werden noch einige
jahre im kämpfer bringen richard pisano
darf in zwei jahren raus und will dann
den park privat erleben das programm gab
mir eine chance und dankt ihm war ich
zum ersten mal im yosemite nationalpark
es ist etwas ganz besonderes dort als
mitglied dieser crew im wald zu arbeiten
brände im nationalpark sind aber nicht
nur eine bedrohung sondern auch ein
wichtiges werkzeug der feuerwehr in
verschiedenen teilen der wälder werden
von mitarbeitern immer wieder gezielt
brände gelegt mit einem besonderen
effekt das kontrollierte abbrennen soll
die regeneration der natur bewirken
für alles was mit feuer im yosemite
nationalpark zu tun hat ist kelly marten
zuständig an diesem tag ist sie im wald
unterwegs und führt zu einer stelle die
sie vor einigen jahren gezielt hat
abbrennen lassen
ich sehe das hier draußen als puzzle
es ist spannend zu beobachten wie die
natur reagiert
drei jahre nachdem wir hier feuer gelegt
haben bekommen wir einen eindruck ob er
gute arbeit geleistet haben
der regenreiche winter hat dazu geführt
dass unkraut verstärkt wächst und so
feuerwehr nahrung geben kann wenn
baumsamen mehr platz haben hat das
unkraut weniger chancen sich
auszubreiten
mit den gelegten bränden hoffen wir
nährboden für neue bäume zu schaffen
in dieser region brauchen die samen
mineralische erde um zu gedeihen unter
der obersten schicht finden wir hier
verbrannte erde
diese samen sind dort gelandet und
konnten wurzeln schlagen ende der saison
am teil der pharma zwischen dem yosemite
nationalpark und san francisco
die enorme trockenheit hatte auf den
mandeln ertrag keinen einfluss
denn während kalifornien und seine
menschen unter dem wassermangel litten
wurden diese pflanzen perfekt versorgt
sie sind eben ein wichtiges wirtschafts
und exportgut
[Musik]
mit dem ergebnis ist landwirt joe del
bosques zufrieden
die erste sieht ganz gut aus
das sind unsere letzten mandeln die wir
dieses jahr bei manchen sorten war die
ernte sehr gut bei anderen durchschnitt
trotz wasserknappheit das geschäft läuft
die anbauflächen haben in den letzten 25
jahren explosionsartig zugenommen
die weltweite nachfrage ist gestiegen
die leute essen mehr mandeln weil es
mehr gibt aus diesem tal kommen 80
prozent aller mandeln weltweit die
nachfrage bestimmt die menge wenn mehr
leute mandeln essen wird der bedarf
größer und dann produzieren wir
vielleicht noch mehr
damit könnte sich das problem um die
wasserversorgung künftig noch
verschärfen
doch solange wirtschafts interessen
wichtiger sind hat die umwelt oft das
nachsehen
1903 gelang es us präsident roosevelt
von der schutzwürdigkeit des yosemite
nationalparks zu überzeugen
bekenntnis zur natur wenn die baxter
fürchtet dass viele ihrer landsleute
dass inzwischen nicht mehr so wichtig
ist
manchmal denke ich ich lebe in einer
ganz anderen welt für mich ist der
klimawandel ganz klar eines der
wichtigsten themen und es ist
frustrierend zu sehen dass wir uns
sozusagen rückwärts bewegen also viele
den klimawandel anzweifeln und erst
recht nichts dagegen unternehmen wollen
für raid level 1 ist dieser park ein
paradies vom zauber seiner wildnis
lassen sich viele begeistern
vielleicht zu viele
die schönheit der natur bleibt die war
schon immer da es ist ein so
wunderschöner ort auf der anderen seite
kommen fünf millionen besucher in den
park
und die kommen nicht mehr um zu sehen
sondern um zu konsumieren bedauert
ranger pitt die wein
[Musik]
ein video ist nicht genug die besten
bilder sind nur virtuelle realität das
ist nicht dasselbe wie hierzu sei es
selbst zehn rausgehen entdecken von john
moore dem begründer des parks stammt das
zitat bei jedem schritt in die natur
bekommt man weit mehr als man sucht
vielen menschen bedeutet der yosemite
nationalpark sehr viel für sie
persönlich ihre familie die kinder und
enkel yosemite wird immer hier sein
[Musik]